uh the White House is responding
somewhat at least to the confirmed
discovery of cocaine near a visitor's
interest and what they're describing as
a well-traveled part of the West Wing
though President Biden opted to grin
through shouted questions about it
during a photo op with Sweden's prime
minister and the subject did come up
again and again in fact during the White
House Press briefing Caitlin Huey Burns
is at the White House for us with the
latest on the response and the
investigation Caitlyn there's a funny
side of this there's a more serious side
to this the president doesn't seem to
want to talk about either one good
morning good morning to you Tony and
good morning to everyone well senior law
enforcement officials say the leading
theory is someone at the White House on
a tour someone on a White House Tour may
have left that small bag of cocaine and
the White House says President Biden has
been briefed on the matter and thinks
it's very important to figure out what
happened
we have confidence that the secret
service is going to get to the bottom of
this as the Secret Service investigates
who brought a small plastic bag of
cocaine into the West Wing the White
House maintains that many people had
access to the area where this was
discovered is a heavily traveled area
where many White House West Wing I
should be even more specific a West Wing
visitors come through the bag was
discovered on the ground floor according
to a senior law enforcement official in
a common area near the entry of The West
Wing it was close to a set of storage
Cubbies where visitors leave their cell
phones during a tour the indications
seemed to me that it probably was
somebody involved in a tour because keep
in mind the Secret Service detail leads
to the White House and the White House
staff are routinely drug tested at
random the White House confirms there
were West Wing tours on Friday Saturday
and Sunday
all visitors are vetted and go through
security before coming on White House
grounds the secret service has a K-9
unit that checks four explosive devices
and biohazardous materials not
specifically for Narcotics visitor logs
and camera surveillance are now being
searched for Clues I think in the end
they'll be able to screen it down well
enough but there is a possibility that
you may never determine who did this
now the incident has caused some to
question the security protocols here at
the White House and how illicit drugs
could be brought in Republican senator
Tom Cotton who's a member of the
Judiciary Committee has written a letter
to the director of Secret Service asking
for a plan to correct any security flaws
Nate
Caitlin thank you